all right guys
bang bang i've got duncan and griffin
back
for round two here we go
we're gonna talk about nfts digital art
all the great stuff thank you guys so
much for doing this
hell yeah thanks for having us yeah
absolutely so as everyone already knows
they're twins which means that they
think alike and they're probably going
to
talk at the same time on the remote
recording but we're we figured it out
we've done a whole logistical test
we're ready to go uh let's start with
just an overview of the traditional art
world maybe griffin you take this one
and kind of explain
how exactly does the traditional art
world work and then we'll get to
the digital art yeah man it's a great
question it's something we've been
researching a lot
since starting nifty gateway because nft
is the first time the real art will just
face disruption the internet didn't
really like disrupt
or change much about it at all but the
real art world is all about
desire it's all about creating a scarce
object
then marketing the hell out of it but
telling everybody but also you can't
have this
you know baskeon is a great example you
hear so much about basquiat
he's this torture genius and he was a
genius you know
obviously he died when he was 27 you
he's not making any more paintings
and all everybody does is talk about him
those are his collectors talking about
him
they're playing up like how big bosque i
was how much he mattered
and like they're just telling you like
his paintings are so worth owning but
you can't have one
and the the supply is always limited and
it always will be limited
and that's exactly how the art world
works they tell you like you should want
this you should want this you should
want this
you can't have this over and over and
over so by the time it does sell
it sells for 100 million dollars this is
why billionaires have
you know like 25 of their net worth in
art because it's an amazing store of
value
art can never be replicated it's scarce
and some of it is just like
insanely significant so it's been really
interesting to learn about and see
and think about how to create those
dynamics in the digital world because
nft's
you know are the first like real
disruption to that and that's something
that can challenge it
there's also a huge element to it of
owning a piece of history
i mean if you're a collector in basquiat
a collector of basquiat in the 80s when
he was
selling his work on the primary market
you know think about how you're doing
now
almost like a lot of physical art
collecting is centers around that it's
like okay
who's who are going to be the artists
that 15 20 years from now
are the ones in the permanent collection
of the moma and the ones where like
you know they're they're widely
recognized as historically significant
artists the art game is all about trying
to figure out who those artists are and
then collecting their
work and holding onto it for 15 or 20
years
for sure and duncan maybe give a quick
overview of like how does this
change in the digital art world right so
everyone knows that uh i've been
investing pretty heavily in the uh in
the digital art world
um i've gone ahead and started
commission pieces
my partner jason has been buying a bunch
of stuff we're pretty convinced but just
give maybe that quick overview of like
what exactly
is digital art and how does the digital
art world work differently
well here's what i like to say i mean
people are amazed that
people are spending you know fifty
thousand a hundred thousand dollars on
nfts
what i like to say is it's actually
amazing that they're spending
50 million dollars on a basquiat
painting when like
you frankly have have no real idea if
it's authentic or not
i mean like someone could have swapped
that out 30 years ago with a perfect
forgery and you have no idea
digital art is the the really
significant part about nfts is
it allows collectibles to be you know
100 guaranteed authentic
for the first time authenticity is a
hugely important aspect of
of what makes a collectible valuable if
a collectible isn't authentic it isn't
valuable
with the physical art world you're
always taking a gamble that
what you're buying like isn't really
authentic that's
i think the main improvement that
digital art has
over physical art like you know it's
going to be authentic plus because of
that baked in authenticity
i think it really raises the number of
art artists that are like actually
collectible
and that are actually going to be you
know their artwork is actually going to
hold value with the physical art world
there's such a high overhead cost
so you know the authentic authentication
selling stuff at sotheby's
it means that unless you're paying 50
000
or above for a work of art it's really
hard to consider that you know
investible or consider that a good store
of value because
below a really high price tier you're
just not going to be there's just not
enough money to pay for
the authentication infrastructure with
nfts and with digital art
authenticity is like baked in which
means that any tier of artists
like you can always go back and find
their work you can always know it's 100
authentic
and it really expands the number of
artists who are like
you know who make work that can be
considered like a true story of value
and like have a shot of being a piece of
history
absolutely and griffin maybe explain a
little bit as to like
why you guys are so convinced that the
digital art world
is the future right do you think it's a
thing where it'll kind of
co-exist with traditional art and be the
same size is it the digital art world
will be bigger than the traditional art
world how do you think about that
yeah i think it'll be much bigger i
think the right analogy is facebook
and magazines right like before facebook
if i wanted to reach
every carpenter in the world i'd have to
put an ad in a magazine dedicated to
carpentry
and now the internet comes along and
there's special groups there's forums
like it connects people in a way that
just like wasn't possible before
internet technology
and you know magazines still exist but
they're a fraction of what they once
were they don't generate nearly as much
ad revenue
and you know most importantly they don't
have as much power before like that was
the only way to distribute information
really was print
and now like the internet came along and
radically improved on print in a number
of ways
and it just it didn't fully eliminate
print but it just made it much less
relevant
it's the exact same here there's like a
technological breakthrough which enables
a new behavior
that was never possible before we're
already seeing all the same disruption
patterns emerge
so it's not that it'll fully replace the
traditional art world it'll still be
there
it'll just be way less relevant way less
powerful and yeah much smaller
yeah i think that's part of what got me
so interested in this is like
when a piece of traditional art is
sitting on the wall the only way that it
changes is if somebody goes and takes
off the wall and puts a new piece
right but now all of a sudden if i put
that
screen there and now i put a piece of
digital art i can have it change it can
have motion it can have sound it can
change by the hour by the season
just by the lighting in the room i mean
there's all kinds of new possibilities
and that's inside of like the micro
level of
just the room in which the art exists or
is being displayed
but then when you look at it from like
the internet okay now all of a sudden
you're saying i don't have to actually
go to the physical
um you know auction or i don't have to
be a member
um or i don't have to have access to
sotheby's for example to
bid on something and have 50 million
dollars instead i can simply go on the
internet 24 7
any time of day and i can use a
marketplace just like the internet has
used for decades now and i can buy a
piece of art
and be anywhere in the world so you're
like expanding both what's possible with
the piece of art but you're also
expanding the investor or collector base
as well right
yeah right you totally are what i like
to say it's like a harry potter
newspaper versus a regular newspaper
the harry potter one is way better it's
magical you know this is like
harry potter art versus regular art
absolutely so
let's talk about the nifty gateway
platform that you guys have built maybe
um duncan you can give us just an
overview of like how the platform
actually works
yeah absolutely i mean nifty gateway is
a
curated art platform we try and form a
thesis about all the artists that we
launch
we really want to bring on artists that
are are prominent and have like
strong career prospects and we want to
act as a partner to them
to help develop their career
that's really important to us we think
that you know curation
is is a really strong it's a huge part
of the the physical art world
at first i didn't really understand why
that is but as i've gotten more into
nfts i've come to understand that
curation
naturally develops in any sort of
collectibles or art market
because on some level like it's
it's a great mechanism for for figuring
out who's like
really serious about it and who's kind
of just you know
experimenting like being a great artist
it's not a it's not a part-time gig
it takes years and years of dedication
extremely hard work
and like blood sweat and tears you know
just like being great at anything
um and like as you know as as curators
we can
we have insight into like who's really
like working extremely hard and
again i'm not trying to say that like we
have every single
great artist so that they're not great
artists not on nifty gateway it's more
like
the value we can provide is figuring out
artists who are promising who are up and
coming
and who are going to and who have great
careers ahead of them and then
presenting them to our audience
we release content in in drops so you
know we
get together a few really prominent
artists and then we help them
you know we help them ideate and
brainstorm on their collections
and then the collections all go live
instantly
a bunch of the drops sell out really
quickly we have a few different
collection formats
you know sometimes we have pack projects
where you buy a piece and you get a
random a random piece from the
collection but
yeah drops our bread and butter and
lately we've been doing a lot more
you know one-of-ones which i think is a
you know we're trying to move more into
the
to that direction than to to like really
appeal to
long-term to like long-term value into
like really
like great artists so yeah that that's
basically like a
quick overview of nifty gateway and it's
taken us a while to get here we've
learned a lot
about how to develop a great art
platform about how to pick the best
artist and something that we're only
getting better at
you know steadily yeah yeah we accept
like
fewer than one percent of the artists
who apply and it is like very selective
um and we do like duncan said we try to
partner with great people
we we don't always get it right there
are some great artists who apply and
like
we turn them down and it turns out like
they are great artists which is
inevitable but
we do try to say everyone who comes on
the platform is awesome and we really
partner with them
we work with you we help you build your
career we like run ideas past you
we're dedicated to working one-on-one
with the artist whereas like all the
other nft platforms
you know they're they're that they're
platforms they don't want to be involved
they don't want to like work with the
artist we're committed to engaging with
them
and so maybe griffin help me understand
one like if i'm an artist and i want to
apply
what can i do to increase the odds of
being accepted
yeah that's a great question um you know
one thing
one thing you can do is kind of like
give us something that
shows you're legit give us something
that shows you're committed to
being an artist for the long term and
that you have the right mindset
reaching out to duncan i directly can
help we're happy to like talk through
your work with you
and then also having a sales record
showing early promise is something we're
really looking for
we're really looking for or a large
audience you know we try to identify who
the promising people are
and bring them on board and if you have
some sort of proven track record already
then that's a really great positive
signal that we look for that's probably
the best way
yeah i think i mean as i said part of
our our promise of the platform is that
we really want to bring in artists who
are
dedicated to it for the long term so
honestly the longer that you've been
making art
the the better i i think it's not too
dissimilar from startups like look at
art as
an artist like you will face a lot of
rejection it's kind of inevitable
and and griffin and i when we first
started nifty gateway we faced a ton of
rejection
i mean like every single vc we pitched
turned us down at first
but you got to be dogged you have to
stay after it you have to like
get small wins and have the small wins
add up um
you know slowly like you'll acquire
traction and like your standing
will improve you'll get more followers
on social you'll get more fans
um and then like eventually once you
know once you
you reach a certain level then like
we'll sort of
become interested in working with you
absolutely and duncan maybe talk a
little bit about if i'm an investor
and i see these drops going on like i've
been on the platform literally
things sell out in seconds what can i do
to either
one increase the odds of of success uh
or two can i do to kind of make sure
that i position myself to get the pieces
that i want
yeah well we actually we have a guide if
you google nifty gateway tips for buying
from a drop
you can see our guide the the key is to
like you got to have your
payment method loaded in advance make
sure you're logged in
during drop time make sure you have the
piece that you're looking to buy
selected make sure you're on that page
changing your computer clock to seconds
can really help
um and like making sure that like as
soon as the the clock hits 7 pm
like you're on it and then honestly you
know a lot of our platform
we've we've done a lot of drops we've
seen the the upsides
but we've also seen the downsides hype
can be sort of a double-edged
sword where you know like on some level
um if you have a really hype drop it can
attract a lot of flippers people who are
not really there to collect the work
long term
who just want to buy it and immediately
resell it so really we're doing a lot of
work to
develop the platform and like add more
stuff in addition to the drops
the drops are great because they really
shine a spotlight on a particular artist
and we've seen it happen many times
where an artist comes on the platform
does a successful drop
and immediately the you know they see
their work on other platforms sell out
and it's really like a great thing for
their career but we're really expanding
to
help artists sell work beyond just the
jobs because it can be kind of a
frustrating experience for collectors
so that means like more one-of-ones for
instance um
you know if you're a collector you can
always go bid on a one-of-one which are
all
they're usually auction based some of
them have list prices but they're almost
always auction based so you can bid on
one of ones
then we also have some other really cool
collection
formats we've been experimenting with
like open editions
open editions basically mean the artist
puts out a piece of work and anyone can
buy it at the list price for a period of
24 hours
um it's great there's no there's
absolutely no flipping it's just people
who want to collect
and often it can be i mean it's it's an
investment in the
the future of the artist long term and
you know like that that should always be
your mindset buying art i think
you should always be willing you should
always be investing in the future of the
artist long term
you should i think if you if you come
into it and you're
expecting to just immediately flip out a
few minutes later
you know it might be it might be
difficult for you and that's not sort of
like a
healthy aspect just just the same way
that if you're like buying into a stock
or if you're buying bitcoin
like you it's much healthier if you're a
long-term
holder you know like uh you want a
warren buffett you don't want like a
high frequency trading firm so those are
really my my pieces of advice
and yeah i i would say like don't get
too hung up on the drops because
a lot more stuff is coming we really see
our value prop as
developing artists um and like bringing
on artists that we think are promising
and then helping them build their
careers
for the long term and really being a
partner to them and and when you're
a partner to the artist and you're
building their careers over that five to
ten year period
naturally you become a partner to the
collectors as well because the
collectors are
you know we're all in it together the
collectors want to see that artist value
go over that five to ten year period
so like it's a very virtuous cycle
absolutely griffin maybe talk a little
bit about what makes an nft
so successful like like the ones that
you've seen right there's
obviously the trevor jones piece that
sold for 55 um there's been a number of
other ones that that have really kind of
grown in value what makes those
successful yeah that's a great question
pomp
um honestly like what makes an nft
successful and valuable is the same
thing that makes any other object
successful and valuable
the meaning behind it you know i think
with
the bulls with trevor jones's bulls
those kind of like hit at the right time
trevor did an amazing job explaining the
meaning behind the piece
he brought in an art historian to talk
about its significance which i thought
was
like a fantastic move um and yeah
there's just like a whole lot of meaning
those nfts like have firmly earned their
place
in nft history and we actually see bids
on those all the time
but you know no one is selling a silver
bull for less than something like 50
000 right now so i don't know those ones
are getting crazy
but yeah it's all about the meaning
behind the project good visuals
good story and like just explain why
it's significant that's something
physical artists
always manage to do too you know they
always
create some sort of movement and create
art that makes you question
like reality in a way that has meaning
so yeah what i like to
compare it to i mean i hate to be a
cliche tech person and
quote zero to one but in zero to one
peter thiel he's like
the next um the next larry page
isn't gonna start google or isn't gonna
start a search engine the next mark
zuckerberg isn't gonna start a social
network
the difficult part about being a great
artist is there's no formula
like the only way to be a great artist
is to break the mold
and to create your own formula so like
the next great artist is not going to be
like banksy banksy was like he was
unique
well i guess maybe it's a group of
people i don't really know but like
what banksy was doing was very unique at
the time they were doing it no one else
had done it before
and that's why it worked it's because
they they didn't just follow the formula
they didn't just release what andy
warhol released they didn't just copy
andy warhol's career
it's like banksy broke the formula so
yeah it requires like true creativity
and like you really have to have a
passion and you have to work at it
constantly for years
and there's really no shortcuts that
unfortunately i mean maybe
i guess like that's that's true of like
all the difficult to obtain things in
life right there's just no shortcuts
totally yeah and one final thing i would
say is there's a
proof of work element to borrow another
you know tech
originated concept it's like if you have
a piece that
can't be replicated it's shown that you
worked on it for a long time like
there's
things that you can only establish by
like working hard eugene way has a
really great post
called status as a service where he
talks about how that's what gets
attention on just social
and mr beast is a great example of this
like he's a video where he sat down and
read the dictionary read an entire
dictionary like front to back like
i don't know that's maybe not the best
example but like something that can't be
replicated
something that proves you put in the
effort and the time you know that
can usually only come with months or
years of dedication and learning
so yeah i also think it's a lot about
the right partner
um you know a lot of artists when
they're just starting off
it's kind of scary building an art
career and we've seen it a lot it
it can be very delicate i i do think i
do like comparing it to a startup
because
you know similar to a startup like you
get traction but like there's a ton of
uncertainty at every step along the way
what this is where we really see
ourselves like adding value and what we
really want to be good at
is like we want to be a partner to the
artists that we're working with almost
like a co-founder
for them on their art careers where it's
like we don't just see the
you know artists like they see their own
career and maybe they have friends
but we see the careers of like a ton of
different artists we have access to all
kinds of like
data from running the platform that
helps us figure out like what
what the best thing to do for an artist
is and we've you know we like
can talk directly to collectors so
yeah i think the right partner can be an
extremely extremely important part of
the
the right art career which is also what
you see in the the physical art world
that's why like the best galleries end
up
you know that's why the best gallery is
like how they how they got to where they
were they became really good at
partnering with artists
and being that co-founder to artists and
that's what
that's what nifty gateway is becoming as
well for sure talk a little bit
uh duncan about the tech deck that you
guys have built and kind of how you as a
company
you kind of are taking the best of both
worlds right you've got the art gallery
type uh structure and model and you can
kind of learn from those
that came before you in the traditional
art world but then you marry that with
technology and really being able to kind
of usher in this digital art world
how do you think about that from like a
tech perspective
right well yeah i think griffin kind of
nailed it earlier when he said
he was talking about facebook versus a a
magazine
the internet enables you to do you know
so many different
crazy things that you weren't able to do
before the internet and and so does
blockchain technology um i mean
the what you can accomplish in the
creative medium of digital art is just
one small example of that we you know
that's
that's like the that's the first example
and i think that's like
the the most salient thing we're seeing
where it's like before you couldn't
really sell
digital animated artwork now you can
sell digital animated artwork
but the second order effects are also
massive and i think over the next few
years they're only gonna
play out more and more where like
for example like if you're an artist the
logistics of shipping a print to a
hundred people
are ludicrous and not to mention the
expense
um it's something that's only available
to a very like small select group of
artists
now artists can connect with their
audience instantly and they can send out
work to a large group of people
instantly there's there's stuff like the
open editions
doing an open edition for a piece of
physical art
you know you maybe could do it for a
print where you like deliver all the
prints afterwards
still really really complex with nfts
that's that's really simple
we also have a lot of other projects you
know we do pack projects
that have a redemption element where if
you collect a certain
you know set completion is always a a
thing present in
in collectibles but like with our
platform if you collect a certain number
of pieces from a drop
then you can automatically redeem that
for a prize nifty and it's all like
it all just happens automatically so
really like yeah that we're just
beginning to witness the second order
effects of
what it means to have internet native
art um
i think we're still in the early stages
of discovering those and
you know like we're always looking to
take advantage of that and always
looking to build features that make it
easier we're also
yeah we also have a lot of cool stuff
that's a little further down the road
where you know we're going to be doing
things like
for the collectors who are who are great
holders
and a really strong patrons of an
artist's work maybe we'll work on a way
of
programmatically rating them and and
figuring out how to like reward the best
collectors
and how to like disincentivize flipping
um
you know we're working on discovery
aspects that use machine learning to
help expose
people to like different artworks
there's a lot of really really exciting
things that you can do once art becomes
internet native
uh yeah and i think like over the next
five to ten years
we're going to see incredible advances
and uh
yeah griffin's facebook to magazine
analogy is really going to play out
in full time yeah griffin anything to
add to that
yeah yeah i was just going to say um our
platform too
we're focused on shipping like crazy and
we're focused on the end user
you know like we went fiat native
and that was kind of like how we
launched and we also have a centralized
exchange and a platform built on custody
which you know we actually have gotten
some flak for on twitter uh there's a
lot of people especially
you know that the blockchain and
decentralization enthusiasts who object
to that
but you know our platform really isn't
for anyone who's
super enthusiastic about the censorship
resistance
and like all those aspects of blockchain
necessarily we cater to them too and you
know we support
purchasing with metamask and everything
but we want to make a platform for
everyone
where anyone can come collect and do it
as easily as possible
that's why we make it super easy to show
up and buy with a credit card
and you know that's we're catering to
we're trying to get that those billion
users onto nfts
and you don't need full decentralization
to get people collecting nfts
so that's like why we built it it wasn't
ideologically driven
it was just how can we make this as easy
as possible for users and that's what
you know we're staying focused on
because we want to give our artists
access to the largest markets possible
and nft the word is spreading people are
starting to understand it and it's a
counterintuitive thing but once
people understand how the tech works
they get really excited about it and
our customers we see a massive amount of
average monthly spend because you know
once they get into it they love it it's
addicting as hell as anyone who's bought
crypto art will tell you so i was just
going to say yeah our tech is
built end to end to be as easy for the
customer as possible and to bring as
many people as possible into collecting
nfts
and we're committed to doing that you
know we're not going to make decisions
based on ideology
we're going to make decisions based on
the customer
absolutely um have you guys ever thought
about creating some sort of
drop where when you buy it you can't
sell it for a certain period of time
like i heard you talk about deep uh
disincentivizing flipping
like it'd be really interesting to
almost have like time lock purchases
where hey when you buy this you got to
hold for five years is there anything
like that
totally we've totally thought about that
and that's something our platform
enables like because of the tech
trade-offs we've made
our platform is much more flexible in a
number of ways than any other
platform really can be because of the
way it's built from the ground up which
is why we have the pac projects
we can also do one-of-ones we can also
do open editions
yeah something like that would be
awesome and what we're focused on right
now is building the infrastructure
so that like our artists can launch with
as many different
types of projects as they want we want
to like leave it up to them
and the producer that they're working
with and if they want to have that
option they should and anytime you build
something for one artist then
it means like any artist can come along
and use it in the future
so yeah we have the largest number of
different project types on nifty gateway
and we're only focused on expanding that
we think the more choice the better
absolutely
um maybe duncan you can talk a little
bit just about like
what's the goal here walk me out 10
years from now like what are you guys
trying to build
what is the vision and kind of how do
you think about nifty gateway a decade
from now
right well when i think about businesses
long-term i always like to think about
the the sort of the question of like if
we get really good at this
like what then we'll win like with
i'll give an example like amazon their
their obsession is like
customers right their obsession is like
quality customer service
and from a very early stage they
basically said okay if
if we get really good at you know
quality customer service we deliver
things on time we make it easy to return
you know we like two day free shipping
all that kind of stuff
then we're gonna win because like that
obsession with the customer is gonna
like
it's so ingrained in our culture that
it's going to uh
propel us to victory for apple it's like
an obsession with building products
it's like okay if we're obsessed with
building the best possible
hardware products and like the software
to go alongside them and like every
single thing we do is making products
that are great
easy to use and like if we do that then
we'll win the market because we have
such great products
for us that thing that we have to get
really good at in order to win the
market
is supporting artists and like
developing their careers again this is
something that we see in the the
physical fine art world where
the you know the most valuable platforms
what the galleries that
that do the best and that add the most
value they're really really good at
developing artists career
and they're really really good at being
that partner to artists um
you know maybe it sounds simple but it's
actually incredibly
difficult and incredibly complex because
managing an art career is so
you know there's many different facets
to it so i think if we get really really
good at
developing artists careers and like
being a good supportive partner to the
people we work with
then that'll be the the driver of
success for our business long
term um yeah i think what duncan's
asking is like
the question we ask ourselves is like
what are we going to do better than
anyone else in the world which is
something that
every company should ask themselves like
what are you going to do
that no other company in the world can
do as well as you because if you don't
have something like that you're not
going to survive
and for us like it's making good nfts
that's what we want to do better than
anyone else in the world just make
awesome nfts
partner with fantastic artists partner
with great people
to build nfts that like matter and just
make nft like
launch nfts that are the absolute best
that's what we're laser focused on
yeah and we've been in the space a long
time i've seen a few different
nft cycles if you will if people
this is not like it's not widely
discussed but right after
cryptokitties we saw a ton of projects
that were just trying to cash in
really like low effort stuff um because
it's
it's actually not that hard to to make
nfts it's never been that hard
to make an nft like all you have to do
is to play a smart contract
if you know what you're doing it's like
pretty simple the only nfts that
survived
were the nfts that like had original
thought had quality
where they'd done something to
distinguish themselves
and i think that's still just as true
today it's easy to get like
it's easy to lose sight of that because
there's way more noise around the scene
now
but again this is like this this is a
game about owning a piece of history
unless you're releasing stuff that has a
chance of being a part of history
then uh you know you're like you're not
going to be around for the long term
and that's that's what griffin and i are
like as griffin said like making great
nfts
and helping our artists like launch
great nfts and develop their careers
that's the thing that we think that we
can be the best at
and that's where like a lot of our
energy is going
absolutely where can people go to uh to
kind of
see everything that's in the secondary
market and also to see in the upcoming
drops
and then click on the marketplace and
see everything we have there twitter is
also really the best way to connect with
us that's where we put the most of our
you know most of our marketing energy at
the moment
um and that just comes from duncan i
being so addicted to twitter in the
first place really but yeah like go
follow us on twitter
that's my best piece of advice go to
niftygateway.com
um sign up for our mailing list we'll
keep you posted on everything there
we try to let everybody know about all
the drops on our mailing list on
niftygateway.com
yeah and then we're about to we're about
to
push out a pretty cool product feature
we haven't really talked too much
publicly about it but it's basically a
discover page
it learns as you as you go so like you
can flip through every
every nifty that's on our site you tell
us what we like and then we have an
algorithm that
like learns your interests and like
serves you up more nifties that you like
kind of like tick tock inspired gonna be
very very cool i
i've really enjoyed playing around with
it it's just a fun place to spend time
you really get to see you like you're
just with all this creativity and cool
art
um so i'm really excited to launch that
absolutely uh i'm gonna wrap this up
with each of you giving a pitch uh
duncan i want you to give the pitch for
artists and griffin you the pitch for
investors or collectors uh griffin why
don't you go first kind of what's your
guys pitch to
uh investors and collectors as to why
they should come use nifty gateway
yeah great question man look we're we're
laser focused on hosting the best artist
and launching the best nfts on our
platform
the nfts that you should care about will
live on nifty gateway
do your own research find an artist's
story make sure they're in it for the
long term
but billionaires have 25 of their net
worth in art for a reason
digital art is porous to be one of the
best stores of value in the 21st century
um and nifty gateways laser focused on
being the forefront of that
and in the center of that so if you if
you're someone who's trying to
buy art collect art and then you know
invest in it for the long term
it's a platform that you just shouldn't
be missing out on
duncan what about the pitch to artist
i think artists have their choice of
platforms nowadays there's more nft
platforms than ever
um and like that's the reason that we
decided to orient our platform around
like being a supportive partner you know
i don't think there's
there's anywhere else you can go to get
the sort of like partnership and
mentorship that we're offering and like
that part of the company is
growing incredibly quickly um
we're really in it in the long term
we're we're aiming to find like
long-term partners
we're not aiming to like have short-term
relationships and we're not aiming we're
not thinking on a short-term time frame
we're really aiming to like bring on
partners that we
are like we are going to promote for the
next five to 10 years and we're going to
be there every step of the way
i think having an art career is scary
it's it's very delicate
it's not it's the kind of thing where it
can easily go wrong
um and that's kind of just the reality
of
of building an art career it's a highly
uncertain industry
what what we're really developing and
what we're really getting better at is
helping mitigate that uncertainty
becoming a true partner for artists and
helping them
develop their careers over the long term
using our unique tools that we have
access to
you know which is like our platform the
data that we see
the the wide variety of different
collections that we see
and then a lot of the expertise of the
the people that we're bringing onto the
team
which is also something we'll be saying
more about but yeah
that's i think where what we do that
that sets us apart
absolutely griffin duncan you guys are
leading the uh leading the charge on
nfts and uh
i'm uh i'm in uh as everyone knows i'm a
believer in uh
in digital art so anyone who's
interested in uh participating in the
drops
seeing any of the secondary marketplace
uh or checking out all the cool stuff
these guys are building go to
niftygateway.com
any last words from either of you before
we wrap this up did you get those
digital art screens hung up in your
apartment i saw i saw polino tweeting
about it
not yet but uh i am uh working on it
we're recording this
during a week where polina has left me
here alone and i've told her i'm gonna
do all kinds of things from buying a
playstation
to ordering dominoes every day to
getting screens installed so
let us know if you need help yeah i
actually have about three or four
screens up in my place
it's pretty awesome not gonna lie it's
really like a
it's a great thing to have in your
apartment like friends come over and you
can show off again it's not just like
one piece of art you can cycle through
all your different art
and you can talk about each piece and uh
you know maybe some of my friends are
bored when i'm just like sitting there
talking about my nft collection but
some of them some of the others are like
wow this is actually really cool and
they like learn about nfts for the first
time
it's really a cool thing so i love
having screens up
i love it i think everyone will
eventually have a screen in their house
don't worry
all right guys everyone go check out
niftygateway.com
and we will have to do this again in the
future thank you guys so much for
joining
thanks thanks paul